back to our panel Tom Bevan
RealClearPolitics co-founder and
publisher Molly Hemingway senior editor
at the Federalists and Mike Allen
co-founder and executive editor of Axios
Molly what perked your ears on all of
that well my colleague Mike Allen here
cheerfully said that Moeller is unafraid
and it's worth remembering that he was
also unafraid when he botched the
anthrax investigation by targeting the
wrong person a blunder that cost
taxpayers quite a bit of money I think
at this point there is definitely a
burden of proof that the FBI Department
of Justice and Special Counsel have to
meet President Trump talked about some
of the conflicts of interests that are
there and Rosenstein actually has quite
a few of them not just what he was cited
for with the letter recommending the
firing of Comey he also was probably the
guy who signed off on Andrew McCabe's
ridiculous investigation into whether
sessions was a Russian spy and he also
is overseeing this u.s. AG who's
investigating FISA abuses of which
Rosenstein was also involved there are
plenty of conflicts going around it
would be good for the media to be
thinking a little bit more about these
conflicts the conflicts in the special
counsel with so many Democrats all of
the problems that we've seen arise out
of what has been able to be pulled there
and it's worth remembering that Congress
has been requesting for a long time just
to find out how did this investigation
into Russia start and the Department of
Justice and FBI are absolutely
stonewalling and obstructing that just
today 3,600 documents go into the House
Judiciary Committee so it's important to
realize there are a lot of moving parts
here on a number of different
investigations both of the FBI and DOJ
and obviously of whatever special
counselor Muller is looking into yeah
and the president there mentioning a
million documents I thought that was new
there's so much news these days they've
said that's 1.4 million documents have
gone from the White House to Muller but
just to hit pause for a second on that
amazing moment that we saw play out the
live play out like that will be picked
over for years look at the president's
body language listen to his tone listen
to his repetition using disgrace
disgraceful again and again saying twice
we'll see what happens John Roberts so
good on what happens when he says that
about you so the president fighting and
this really plays into what he's been
trying to do for a while we've seen the
discrepancy and his lawyers strategy and
his
the lawyers have wanted to cooperate
told him assured him that it would pay
off for him to cooperate the president's
been resisting he's been wanted to fight
he's been wanting to discredit the molar
findings with his base and this does it
big time you know it's interesting just
to think about what exactly and we don't
know what Muller may have found that
referred to the US attorney in New York
but having the politics of all of this
swirl around at the same time meanwhile
Tom this is one week ahead of Jim
Comey's book that's coming out right it
is as these investigations are going on
on Capitol Hill Muller has to know that
he crosses a line in at least the
president's mind as he's negotiating
with the president to sit down by doing
this so you wonder how you get to that
point yeah look I thought the
President's speech wasn't me it was it
was a Greatest Hits I mean he went
through combing Hillary Clinton lies
jeff Sessions recusal molar conflict
Rosen Stein I mean it was it was a
recitation of the greatest hits
obviously he's upset and as britt hume
mentioned earlier the only crime that we
know of that might be connected with us
right now is an FEC violation and so you
know over here Trump starting with
collusion with Russia and now we're
looking at a private attorney private
attorney of the president being raided
by the FBI no-knock raid it's a pretty
said early it's a pretty dramatic
increase in the in the stakes of this
investigation and I would not be
surprised the other thing that everyone
has told Trump not to do is to fire Bob
Mona and and I suspect he might be going
on his own gut now and thinking you know
what I've been right on this all along I
might want to do it so I mean just put
this in context this is a live
presidential statement about a raid on
his personal attorney's office that
deals with communications were told that
had tied to an alleged affair with a
porn star and a payoff days before the
election as he sits there and
contemplates whether to strike Syria and
retaliation for a chemical weapons
attack I just want to put that in
perspective
as people are getting their head around
all this and there is that subtext to
that the president talked about which is
there has been an active resistance
movement since the moment he was elected
and they kind of go from item to item in
an attempt to bring him down so that is
part of the context there and he kind of
unlike a lot of presidents he's so
transparent and how he speaks he just
talks about what is actually going on in
this moment but it's worth people
thinking about as they do their
resistance which is you know you're
right as an American citizen to do
whether it's worth bringing instability
at this time for some of these issues
going on one more pivotal thing the
president quadrupling down on fire and
called me remember Steve Bannon said
that was the biggest mistake in recent
political history the president saying
twice there he was right and that fits
with what you were saying about how he's
now feeling about Bob mark although
referencing rod Rosen Stein's letter
saying this is what should happen
whether that was written you know after
and how and when well the entire
question I think right now is either
there is treasonous collusion between
Trump and Russia or there is an FBI and
Department of Justice that is completely
out of control you think it's one of the
two well I would love to see any
evidence for the first claim that we
have been spending so much time on we
have a lot of evidence to support the
second claim the Washington Post at this
hour is saying that the the raids dealt
with FEC violations and bank fraud we
have no way to confirm that if that's
possible and and it's separate it seems
like it's separate from Muller and he's
referring something that he finds this
is all speculation until you find out
what they're looking at right as I said
earlier when you have a news breaking
news event like this there's the fog of
war a lot of questions are raised we
don't have a lot of answers to them it
will become clear in the coming you know
days and weeks exactly what again who
proved this how did the process go how
did we end up it's kind of unusual for
Muller to bounce this up to the district
attorney in New York or to have Rosen
saying sort of given the approval to do
that and then again what was the after
what did he find what was he looking for
and how is that connected to Trump in
any way or if it's not you know then is
Michael Cohen just collateral damage is
little in this whole affair Brett that
Washington Post Bulletin a single source
but from a reliable
porter and a reminder that this
investigation is moving so much faster
than a special counseling usually does
and faster than we thought this was
moving all right in the in the other
politics here you heard him the
president talked about military funding
funding for shoring up the military as
he considers military action now he is
trying to get congress to rescind some
of the 1.3 trillion dollar spending bill
that he signed and actually threatened
to veto at one point that when they were
going to pass it and the concern about
the CBO projections which we're going to
get into from from capitol hill all of
this playing on the same day yeah and
rescission is this idea of rescinding
some of that spending is important not
just because republicans have liked to
think of themselves as fiscally
responsible and this 1.3 trillion dollar
omnibus was anything but fiscally
responsible the base of the party is
very upset with that kind of spending
spree and there is an option where you
only need a simple majority in congress
in the senate to rescind some of that
bloated budget and the leaders in the
house and the senate can just suggest to
donald trump what he suggests they
rescind and get those votes through that
would be not just good for the fiscal
health of the country but it's
absolutely important for a base that is
wondering why have republicans in each
branch if they are not going to actually
govern as they claim they will